Curb Your Enthusiasm I had the honor
it's in its ninth season yeah and I had
the privilege of every now and then I
run into Larry David and you're talking
to him and I I was at a table of people
that were eating dinner with them and I
was thinking to myself this guy must get
pitched so many ideas because everybody
must think Oh something funny happened
to me and it would be a perfect episode
of Curb Your Enthusiasm and then I
thought okay I have to ask you I didn't
ask Larry but the camera down yeah this
one that's mine now did you did you did
you yeah no one's gonna stop me and then
you can't arrest it in this town that's
a bad thing anyway so you get pitched
ideas a lot I get pitched constantly and
you know what I'm glad we're on TV don't
pitch me and I'll tell you what so
people come up to me and go I've got the
best idea for Curb Your Enthusiasm and I
let them know no one in the nine years
that we've been doing the show has ever
pitched me an idea that I went I'm gonna
bring that to Larry that's great they
all stink like give me an example what's
an example of one yeah fat lady cut in
front of me in line at the salad bar
yeah wait that's the whole idea
no that was he I get it someone pitch to
him pitch that to me and I go well what
what's funny about that well it was
crazy I didn't know what to say so I
said you shouldn't cut and it was a real
curb moment tell him so I tell these
people don't pitch me none of them work
and then they say if you'll do something
they pitch me and again I go I told you
not funny what do you mean I go not
funny here's how you why you shouldn't
pitch me I'm on Curb Your Enthusiasm I'm
one of the producers of Curb Your
Enthusiasm
I don't pitch Larry David I have never
told him an idea and I work on the job
don't work on the show leave me alone
hey Murray here tonight he's a genius I
don't need atonement yeah you know if
everyone could do it everyone would do
it but then I can't do it what I come up
with the funny ideas night funny Diane
Keaton says funniest money what yeah
really yeah I know she's not gonna be
happy I'm quoting her but um no friends
with my wife and she keeps on saying
about my kids being funny like funnies
money
you're good funniest money and I love
that funnies money wait she means me you
make a good salary you're funny
go with it okay if she's such a funny
thing I don't equate Diane Keaton saying
that kind of thing at all you know yeah
funny bunnies money that kids going
place to see this is something Diane
Keaton to me fart that Diane no it's not
the Diane Keaton that doesn't Edward G
Robinson Keaton really talks I'm telling
you I see her yeah I was in Annie Hall
you